so this is just a tip that when you
approach investors
come with the confidence um understand
that you're coming into a marriage
and you're choosing the person as much
as he's choosing you
[Music]
thank you for joining my show for the
second time how are you
i'm good thank you for having me
of course of course okay so uh you know
just today we have
the huge fires all over california so i
appreciate you being flexible
and hopefully by the time that this airs
there will be no more fires
but but in any case thank you for
joining me
with pleasure wonderful wonderful okay
so
i have to start again from the fun fact
because it's so much fun
and the first fun fact that that you
told me about is the fact that you're
able to hold boiling pots
without getting burned how is that
possible or with getting burned but
without feeling pain actually
right yeah i just don't feel it um so
basically you can say i'm a hero and
this is my superpower
um i just i can hold it and don't feel
anything i will
still burn though you will still burn
you actually showed me before that you
had some burn marks but but again but
i have to i have to understand you're
literally you can go and hold a boiling
pot
but you're not going to feel the pain
yep
that's that's just unbelievable but
that's that's just the first fun type
the second one
which is which you have an interesting
story back from the army and you
discover
by chance that you're colorblind now i
have to understand first of all
how how is it possible that only only at
the age of 18 or 19
you get to a point where you understand
that you're colorblind it must not be
that severe right
um so i don't know about severe but i
was always told that i have really bad
taste in clothes
so um but yeah in the army just like
i was in the intelligence force and
everybody is writing something from the
board i'm like looking to the left to my
right
i really don't understand what's
happening um and then i just realized
that i don't see anything because i'm
colorblind which it makes sense my
father is colorblind
um but for female it's pretty rare you
need both parents
interesting okay so you need both
parents to be colorblind
for females to be colorblind you have
the gene you have to have that
a recessive gene i guess right
unbelievable okay so so stop you you're
you're an investor an entrepreneur
you ran an accelerator you're you know
you're very knowledgeable about but
the israeli ecosystem but specifically
about the jerusalem tech ecosystem which
i'm especially curious about and today
you're investing with
with live zo2 so i'd love to start off
with your journey
you know take me back to the old days
when when you're just starting out your
your entrepreneurial experience in
jerusalem
how do you make your way what are the
biggest milestones towards you becoming
an investor
as a part of labs walk me through those
that journey
sure so basically i consider myself to
be
a social entrepreneur um back in 2012
i co-founded siftac and was the ceo it
was the first entrepreneurship center
and first accelerator in greater
jerusalem basically
our mission was um to help young people
like us stay in the city
um and and build companies and startups
and um there were no startups in the
city back then
so you know like any pitch like what why
what is the
what is the pain point like why do you
have to create
different mechanisms to help to have
people stay in jerusalem i love
jerusalem why would people leave it
so i think that the biggest problem for
young people was basically employment
and um so you can work for the
government but if you want to do
anything else and if you have an idea
and you want to become
an entrepreneur and israeli startup
nation right
um you basically would have packed your
bags and moved to tel aviv because this
was the only ecosystem in israel
um and we wanted people to be able to
stay in jerusalem although they want to
become entrepreneurs
and we thought that this is a big um
maybe a major milestone
to develop jerusalem economy um so we
did that
in 2012 later on we really uh um
we were part of the group that founded
the community
uh of entrepreneurs in jerusalem
um i think that the next milestone was j
next uh back then it was the prime
minister office the jerusalem
development authority
and the jerusalem municipality so i
founded
the project to develop jerusalem economy
through high-tech entrepreneurship
um my next stop was at our crowd
okay to build basically the platform for
a value creation to connect
all the tens of thousands of accredited
investors
to uh the portfolio companies for
business development purposes but not
only for also for real flow due
diligence and stuff like that
and then i gave birth the day after we
launched
uh the day after you launched wow
yeah during our crowd summit it was on
uh
thursday and i really remember john
telling everybody
i was the last speaker and like you just
wait
maybe we're gonna have like live birth
on stage
um luckily we didn't only the day after
wow
unbelievable and then during my
maternity leave
um i realized that's basically my dream
is to
uh to do venture creation uh to build
companies base
based on academic institutions ip
and then we founded labzo2 so we're an
early stage seed fund and incubator
and we invest in early stage companies
but also we do venture creation and we
have a partnership
with the university of jerusalem
and we're working with
professors and doctors to really try to
see how we can take their technology and
turn it into a company
fascinating so i so i am aware that the
the default
way of starting a company is you know
you have a couple of people who are
coming together they agree on
on a problem they then they think of a
solution and then they go and bring that
and hopefully find a good go to market
and a product market fit but what you're
saying here is that with a
with a venture creation a lot of times
you're going into these academic
institutions and you're taking
technology and solutions that don't
necessarily even have a problem yet and
you're finding ways to adapt them is
that the way that it works
uh basically yeah it's not only that
it's also like build a team
uh so it's everything it's really
understanding the technology
um trying to think what you can do it is
usually you have plenty of
uh of ways um of
solutions and problems that it can solve
uh do market research
uh talk a lot with the industry and try
to understand exactly
which is the biggest problem that
they're solving the biggest need
and then bring in um along with the
professor
um the relevant team usually by the way
the professor stays in the academics not
usually
always he stays in the university he
becomes an advisor she's a scientist
officer
um okay and then and then what and so so
how is that life cycle different than
than
you know the regular startup so they
start you're helping them do the market
research form a team
and then maybe down the line invest i
guess because you're not you mean
it sounds like the beginning is more of
a you know the mentorship
type of type of engagement and then it
be and then it becomes sort of a
pre-stage
pre-seat and a seed stage investment yes
we're really working with them uh for a
period of time
this takes time uh usually when a
company comes and they pitch
so it will take a couple weeks a couple
of months like tops
to decide to invest here we're talking
about a process that can take up to a
year
um but when we're happy with the results
we're putting in the money
and we can move forward so then how do
you how do you divide your time because
it sounds like you know you have
if you have a few of those ventures that
are that are you know almost a year-long
process and
there's only a finite amount of time and
resources that labzo 2 can provide
how do you how do you you know divide
that up
so we invest in around six companies per
year we won't do
more than two venture creations uh per
year okay
so so you're focusing so you so you're
you're the venture creation is even
more exclusive than the it's even more
selective than the investments
for sure it takes time we can't really
do six like they say i wish i could
but i really can't right 100 so so one
of the things that we that we talked
about before which was a really
interesting to me
is this sort of the do's and don'ts of
an early entrepreneur going to their
going to the first investors and and i'd
love to get your take on
your impression having met so many
entrepreneurs and so many companies
what are some of sort of the pitfalls
that you notice that young entrepreneurs
make as they start their journey and
approach their first
f a institutional funding
so i actually have a full lecture about
it but i'll maybe pick like the the best
ones
so i think um that the first one is
really that it's all about the personal
connection so a lot of the times um
entrepreneurs come they sit down they
connect the computer
and they start to talk so the problem
we're solving and the solution and
guys wait for a second let's talk it's
like a relationship
um it's not an interview right you need
to form a connection with the person
because if you're if if i'm going to
invest i'm going to work very closely
with you
i want to make sure not only um that
you're
that you know what you're talking about
that you're tackling
a relevant problem that your solution is
good i want to find out first of all
who are you and are you the kind of
person that i want to work with
so just start by getting to know the
person
and maybe it can lead me to how to
really connect and how to approach
so a warm introduction i think is always
the best way to go
um but i think it's really important to
say that
even if you don't you can't find a warm
introduction
a cold email is okay just do your
research
so go and see my interview for example
uh for 20 minutes
and um talk and just write something
about something specifically i said that
i don't know clicked um
go to try and find out if someone if you
if the investor wrote anything
he did a ted talk um go into his
portfolio companies
and see which kind of company he invests
in
so when you're writing an email a cold
email
just make sure that's by the way that's
fine but just make sure it's not
um the same email you're sending
everyone
because if an investor gets an email
that he sees that
everyone got the same email and it's a
cold email
he's probably going to pass um from
scratch so
this is like a small something that you
you can do pretty much right away
um i think that another thing is that
um you you must be proficient in what
you do
so i know that a lot of people are
starting with like uh
a story about themselves and how they
encounter the problem but
i really don't think that that's enough
just to that you encounter the problem
it really needs to be something that you
dealt with you worked with
um not just something that occurred one
day but
something time you you've thought a lot
about it you're
and you're proficient uh in the field
that you're talking about i think that
this is
super important um i think that even for
pre-seed and seed investors it's very
important
to do as much as you can by yourself
so um by the way it's fine to come to an
investor with a presentation only
but also just with a presentation
just show that you gave us some thoughts
um that you did your
research your as much research as
possible
if i know more about the subject than
you do that's not a good thing
um so really do as much as possible and
there's i
i understand it's not anyone not
everyone can really like
put everything on hold and now focus
solely on their uh
company and build it from scratch and
that's okay you don't have to get
to paying customers but as much as you
can
try to do um on your own no but but
there is something
that that speaks to this idea of you
know being scrappy and bootstrapping and
being able to leverage whatever
minimal resources you have starting out
and coming with and coming with some
good foundation and not necessarily you
know with paying customers
you know a lot of times investors don't
even expect to see that
up until the seat or the series but but
at least coming with
with proof that you as a team can
leverage whatever small resources a
precedent investor can provide you
because
those few hundred thousand dollars or
those few million dollars
they're not going to be the deciding
factor of whether you were
you're able to execute well they might
help you get there but at the end the
team
it's how you leverage those minimal
resources right
exactly and we're taking a risk right
you're sitting in front of us and you're
selling us
a dream by the way i love the jobs being
an investor
specifically in like the pre-seed seed i
don't need to start like
i'm not going to the excel month oh yeah
revenues i see the hockey stick
like i get to see the people's dreams so
like that's the best job ever right
but i'm still taking a risk and i do
want to see that you took some risk
as well so just try to do as much as
possible
um anyone's i want to say something else
uh just uh uh food for thought so
i see the relationship like like i
mentioned
earlier i see it as a two-way street so
it's not only that you're coming in and
you need to impress me
and and sell um i really do think that
um what you can do for me if you're
asking an investor what he can do for
you is
super valid questions and i want to see
more entrepreneurs
actually ask this i want i want them to
to understand that they know they don't
only need money they need
value and to choose investors based on
the value
so i will say i had quite a lot of
companies that i
i said no to not because they weren't
good not because i didn't have the
personal connection
just because i thought that i wasn't the
right investor i didn't think that i can
bring
um additional um extra added value
um and that's important so this is just
a tip that when you approach investors
come with confidence um understand that
you're coming into a marriage and you're
choosing the person
as much as he's choosing you right so
what is your number one turn off
uh that when when somebody approaches
you you see a lot of companies what is
like one thing that really makes you
tick and not
perhaps just you but but you know the
the average investor
maybe arrogance and um
probably um the biggest problem i think
uh is um lack of diversity
so i think that a lot of the time you
can see when
it's a group of men only
just because they still haven't
recruited the relevant
uh people and but this is like part of
their culture
or just because they're men like man and
then and that's it um i think that
this is by the way i think this is a big
problem for industry
um the lack of diversity is
for me it's a big problem no no
definitely and this is something that
comes up often in the series with
and a lot of others that i've spoken
with we spoke extensively about about
the role of
you know about the responsibility of
having diversity
from both the investors side but also
the founders side and
and on on the opposite side of this
question of what makes you take out
what what really makes you excited so
what quality
or what happens and that makes you
really excited when you meet in your
entrepreneur you're like wow like this
is somebody that i might really want to
work with
so when they're super super excited
about what they're doing
and when i really i really love um
crazy ideas basically so the crazier
the crazier the better for my home from
my perspective
uh but really when you see like this i
don't know this professor from the
university and he's coming
and he's talking to about like quantum
physics and he's super excited and he's
sure
that this is the most exciting topic in
the world
um i'm excited as well like uh
i love it i love it no i remember i i
had a i had a great conversation with
george berman from innovation endeavors
a while back and one of the and you know
the whole thesis their whole thesis is
moonshot ideas
and i was just so inspired by this
notion of investing based on the idea
that
you're only going to go for the
companies that have a shot
at changing the world in a really
substantial way so i love this idea of
the crazier the better but stop
you know you gave a tip that for anybody
who wants to to approach labzo too
it should should get to know you better
so i'd love to get to know you better
myself and hopefully one day i'll also
come and pitch a company to you
but talk to me a little bit about what
you're passionate about so
you know you see all these different
companies all the different industries
what really makes you excited about the
entrepreneurship world
and what types of projects do you do you
really get excited about
what kind of so i i have to say that
we're pretty generalists
so we're excited about a lot of things
uh but we are looking to solve like big
problems
you call it uh shooting to the moon and
i actually i love it
um so it's really hard for me to pick a
specific sector
um but um i think
what gets me excited if it's like big
ideas that are going to change the world
um i love the fact that in each one of
my portfolio
companies i can really see the impact
we're not impacted investors this is not
what we base our decision upon
uh but still like if you go through and
patrol my portfolio company
you can actually see like the how
they're going to affect and change
something in the world
each and every one of them so um
this on my personal level this gets me
excited
so take me back to the portfolio
companies your agnostic your
generalists this time i'm gonna hear you
okay so uh we're pretty generalist
we're looking for people that are
solving big big problems sorry
futuristic um with like deep technology
uh but on a personal note i really like
companies
that has an impact we're not an impact
fund but i love the fact that if you
look at our portfolio companies
you'll see that each one of them really
is making an
impact um and the sector
i would say that uh my new passion is
maybe new york tech
so okay what do you love about that why
why specifically that
i think basically uh we're gonna see i
think that this is the field that's it's
only it's only
in the beginning um and i think that
we're gonna
see much more there's pretty much we
know very little about our brain
uh so we have a lot more to explore and
um i love the fact that until today i
think that
most of the company that we saw was very
um
you had to put something on your head
not to say in your head
and we're now going to a phase where
it's
going to be uh non-invasive completely
so
you you're going to be able to i don't
know like um
just make your brain work better with
without really hurting him
so that's that's interesting i love it
okay so along the same lines of getting
to know you i have to ask
the most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself and
why why those three specific words
okay um so i would say i'm an
entrepreneur
i really like to build things i have to
say that i don't really like to measure
them
afterwards but i like to build things
but that is why um
being an investor is really really suits
me right
um maybe the second word will be
smile so i'm a very happy person
and i smile a lot and
this is the way i want to live my life
so when i was really young
my mother told me that if i'm not happy
about something just
walk away just um you don't have to stay
in a place where you're not happy
and i did that so um
i smile most of the time i think and
um the last thing that described me
talk so basically it's really hard for
me to shut up
i love it explain a little bit more
so um i think that i know a lot about
a lot of topics so i can talk to you
about like
all these kind of different things um if
you try to to go
like indeed in depth to some of them
maybe it won't work as well
but but i love it so we can like jump
from one topic to another and i can
really
um hold the conversation for a couple of
hours
i love it stuff thank you very much for
your time and generosity
thank you for first thing with all the
mishaps with the fires and the internet
but
but but we but we managed to get this
and this was just wonderful and very
insightful
and and stay safe and stay healthy thank
you very much you too
wonderful